la justice israélienne doit se prononcer
sur les expulsions de familles
palestiniennes à jérusalem-est
quatre familles palestiniennes ont fait
appel car elles risquent d'être expulsés
de leur propriété selon leur avocat il
semble peu probable que la cour rende
une décision dans la journée elle cette
affaire d'expulsion a été l'un des
éléments déclencheurs dans à la dernière
flambée de violence en mai dernier
et pour en parler justement nous étions
tout à l'heure avec jacques benillouche
en 1956 des réfugiés au haram ont quitté
israël à la suite de la guerre
d'indépendance et se sont réfugiés en
cisjordanie qui était à l'époque sous
mandat jordanien vous savez que la
jordanie avait un mandat depuis 1921
jusqu'en 1967 date de la guerre
d'indépendance
donc ces familles se sont installées
dans au nord de jérusalem
à cheikh jarrah et l'agent d'avis et
l'inra qui est l'organisme l'organisme
dead aux réfugiés palestiniens ont
décidé de construire des logements pour
ces familles qui ont été je dirais
réfugiés cette installation s'est fait
sur des terres qui appartenaient à des
juifs avant la guerre d'indépendance et
donc c'est pourquoi ce problème a
rejailli il à rejaillir aux environs des
années 60 le la jordanie avec garantie à
ces populations qu'elles leur donnerait
un titre de propriété
dès lors que la construction sera
terminée et deux ou trois ans après
seulement le problème c'est que la
guerre des six jours est intervenue et
les 167 et la journée la jordanie n'a
pas pu donner à ces populations des
titres de propriété